elles sont cinq dans les yvelines la
maison france services de sartrouville
et la 1300e du pays
son but accompagné des citoyens dans
leurs démarches administratives pour
pallier les difficultés d'accès au droit
les citoyens peuvent avoir des réponses
à des questions de la vie quotidienne
d'accompagnement pour refaire une carte
d'identité pour demander des apl pour et
posé une question de droit l'équipe de
sartrouville accueille 250 personnes par
mois
elles viennent vérifier leurs démarches
ou encore connaître leurs droits
objectif de l'établissement concentré en
un seul lieu plusieurs services publics
ici il existe une dizaine d'institutions
c'est un lieu où les personnes peuvent
venir et résoudre leur problématique que
ce soit aussi bien pôle emploi que la
caf que la cnav donc la retraite donc
c'est vraiment on va dire une
institution qui on regroupe des
institutions publiques les maisons
france services se situent dans des
zones très rurales ou semi rurale ou
encore dans des quartiers politiques
prioritaires de la ville comme c'est le
cas ici à sartrouville
le besoin est encore plus accrue parce
que les citoyens les administrés sont
très éloignés des services publics et
donc ils ont besoin qu'on vienne vers
eux qu'on les aide qu'on les accompagne
on sait qu'il ya des vrais problèmes
d'accès au droit aujourd'hui d'accès aux
droits sociaux d'accès à la justice
une campagne de communication a été
lancée pour faire connaître ses services
de proximité
objectif comptait 2000 maisons
françaises dans le pays d'ici la fin de
l'année